[Music]
so far my stay at vermont's juniper inn
has been shocking
[ __ ] and the root of the problem is
beginning to show you don't get paid
i've seen with my own eyes how poorly
this place is run
but now i need to see what happens to
the bottom line
when robert and aria use juniper hill as
their own private playground
entertaining all their friends
i'm hoping estate manager ryan can help
me a lot of the staff are telling me
their um friends pop up from manhattan
and come and spend weekends and sit
drink and be merry are these guys
actually pain
ah no robert had a slew of friends come
and stay for free and eat for free for
weeks at a time and that's why they've
been losing money since i've been here
what do the colors mean help me
understand that green means they're paid
in full red means they have not paid oh
my god i have 50 room nights that's
between november and december just an
average they're 200 a night for this
it's like 10 000 in revenue that's ten
thousand dollars
they're running it they're almost like
house at clubhouse almost like they're
trying to buy friends and
robert prides himself as the superior
business person robert walks around like
he's the king and that everybody hears a
bunch of hicks this is insane this is
like a private club for him he's worked
with the servers before and accepted a
portion of the tips oh my god
[ __ ] hell
he's taking their bloody tips
and this guy is mad i can't believe this
he doesn't pay them and then he takes
their tips i gotta talk to him
how are we barbara how are you today
good i'm just out of interest
is it true that robert takes a
percentage of the tips yes he does yeah
and what percentage of tips does he take
what we get
he gets the same as you yeah it's really
hard to keep track of the tips i at the
the bookkeeping it
doesn't it seems inconsistent why is he
touching the tips he did the same thing
for new year's they felt that because
they needed to cover part of the band
that they took the tips off
our tip
that's why we don't make anything here
an owner has no right to take the
staff's tips and with all the room and
food comps robert is giving his friends
it's no wonder the inn is struggling
the staff shouldn't be subsidizing the
end so robert and his friends get to
live the high life for free it's
sickening i have to confront him and
figure out this nonsense
i just had a look round and i just
i am flabbergasted i'm going to be
really frank i'm going to try to stay so
calm but if i smell but yes that you
start going into denial i'm going to let
rip again
i studied your reservations
last november december 49 rooms were
given out for free
and on top of that
they ate
they drank
for nothing they're not even tipping and
i'm just what the [ __ ] are you doing
tell me why i thought i
needed to have somebody here rather than
having two other guests in the hotel all
by themselves
to have more energy
making it worse not only do your friends
not leave tips but when people do tip
the staff you take a share on nights
that i work
i did take time that is disgusting
why do you think you are right to that i
have tried to work with my staff to
teach them that this is the way i want
service done feels so bad i take a
percentage of the tips based on the
amount of work that i do and who does
the books on those tips um ari
but if i'm doing their job and i can't
get it across to them you're the owner
you're not the head busboy you're not
the bar man
you're the [ __ ] owner
what i was saying wasn't getting through
so the psychology was that if i started
to take tips they would maybe pay
attention to that that is insane it's
the worst management model i've ever
heard in my entire life
do you honestly need a 70 year old
lady's tips
[Music]
so
15 20 grand worth of complimentary rooms
in the food in a two-month period i'm
just doesn't make sense i have to tell
you that the reason i did that was
because i thought that they would at
least tip my staff but they didn't tip
your staff
sorry to piss on your bonfire well then
i will call my friends and i will tell
them look what happened you haven't got
the [ __ ] balls to call your friends
and ask them to leave a tip yes i do
call them them
and ask them i thought at least out of
generosity you would have left a couple
hundred dollars tip for the team hello
dana
it's robert you stayed here recently
and um i was under the impression that
you and greg left a tip did you leave a
tip
no no no but you said you were going to
send additional tip
i think my time's done here that was one
of the things that i was hoping you had
done um if i didn't do i was supposed to
i'm very sorry and
i left the money with you wait a minute
there's others to call too
gordon oh dear
gordon has left he thinks i'm stealing
my staff's tips unbelievable
judge
hey ray it's robert did you tip the
staff because they're telling people
that they haven't been tipped
i left the money with you
oh so i need to do that
i i somehow lost that
[ __ ] idiot
gordon left
thinking i'm a liar
i feel as if i'm
i'm at the end of my room
i mean i'm going to lose everything i'm
gonna have to start all over again if
this doesn't work
[Music]
i just don't seem like i
can do it
i know i can't do it
[Music]
i've just left juniper hill after
catching robert in a lie about a staff
getting tips i was under the impression
that you and greg left a tip
did you leave a tip
the guy is maddening and i don't know if
i've got it in me to help fix the place
i'm so pissed off with robert right now
honestly i cannot stand any more of his
bloody lies
this guy doesn't deserve the team that
is in his hotel he treats everyone so
badly when you're in your [ __ ]
kitchen all day long and you're on the
internet instead of actually trying to
perfect the menu it doesn't even pay
them properly i had to wait five weeks
before i got a paycheck i worked very
long days and i haven't been paid in
three weeks
how can someone so rich not pay the
people he employs
that's something i simply won't stand
for
as angry as i am i feel i have to help
the staff get paid
and i have an idea of just how to do it
i'm going to hire a team of white club
movers to assemble all of robert's most
valuable antiques from the storage units
the basement and around the inn
i'm hoping when confronted with all the
money he's wasted i can convince robert
to sell some of his vast collection to
pay his staff
if this is going to work i must stay
calm while i talk to robert
um
i've come back
not for you but for the staff they
deserve better
we're losing on average 15 to 20 000 a
month
and we are
short
but you have a serious hobby of sort of
an art collector an art dealer i mean
you could open a museum how many pieces
you have in this oh my god hundreds what
we're talking about everything
collectively
all those beautiful oil paintings the
expensive stuff at a suitable auction
um maybe three hundred thousand dollars
three hundred thousand dollars and that
would supplement you for the next 12
months 18 months yes that would
certainly get us through
that would get us through two years um
right there's something i want you to
see yeah i'd like you to come with me
please
if there's one thing we need right now
is an injection
of funds
wow
robert no man alive needs this much
stuff
walking in it was shocking now
antiques oil paintings
silverware
does it not i mean frustrate you that
we're sat with all this
and yet we can't pay our staff properly
there's someone i'd like you to meet
she's the head auctioneer at bonhams in
boston amy good morning good morning
gordon uh nice to see you gordon great
to see you that was thank you so much
for coming um we're in the [ __ ]
basically and this stuff needs to go we
need to raise as much money as possible
so what's the best price we can get for
all this stuff
[Music]
what you have here doesn't read as a
collection to me it's kind of an
accumulation
a lot of copies of things
or if they are of the period that
they're supposed to be there's some
condition issues
[Music]
i would say
about twenty five
thousand say that again 25 000.
25 000
all this
all this
amy's opinion on our our things was
shocking and i can't really believe that
and the painting the painting is a copy
and not a good one i'm afraid how much
that work i can't imagine what someone
would pay for it it's really very low
value wow robert i thought you said it
was expensive 18th century well it's
dated i dated 17. it is but it's not
actually of that period at all
i'm sorry
did you know that was a copy i did not
know that that was a copy
lots of copies reproductions
reproductions we're hoping in the
ballpark of three to four hundred
thousand twenty-five grand for
everything
yeah that won't even get us through the
next five weeks even all this amazing
silverware i put a hundred dollars on
everything on this table a hundred
dollars what about this first period
this sheffield yeah it's plate what
about this 175 bucks those are vodka
candlesticks they just don't bring very
much at auction i'm afraid is this the
kind of collection you'd be willing to
sell at bottoms would you take the whole
lot no we wouldn't wow we would have to
say no
we're floating as if we've got this
asset full of three or four hundred
thousand dollars worth of antiques we
haven't and we're distracted with the
bits of crap in here it was a wake-up
call
thank you that's the start appreciate it
thank you it means that we don't have
the backup that we thought we had
we've paid more money for [ __ ]
storage than they were then they're
worth does that not bring it home a
little bit earlier that you need to be
an innkeeper not a part-time antiques
dealer
because you fooled me
you gave me the tour and i thought wow
this guy is uh
he's got serious cash to burn
but right now we're even further in the
[ __ ] than i thought we were
so the pressure
intensifies yeah you need to focus on
fixing the business because that's
what's going to generate sufficient
funds to keep this place open
and i don't think you quite realize that
your staff
they're miserable
they don't like aries barking excuse me
excuse me
i am the boss you bitching when you're
in your [ __ ] kitchen all day long and
you're on the goddamn internet instead
of actually trying to perfect the menu
it's not a nice atmosphere for the staff
currently
and if they quit
you're [ __ ]
they are staff they're not pigs that
live in the [ __ ] basement
if you think that's not the case and
you're that delusional and you're not
prepared to listen to anything i'm
saying you're [ __ ]
sell the in
sell this [ __ ] in here and give up
i've just come back to try and save
juniper hill in and i thought i could
use some of the owners vast array of
antiques to get the cash flowing
but i've just discovered
i would say about 25 000. 25 000. all
this all this
then i was wrong
that won't even get us through the next
five weeks
with no assets the challenge to make
this place work is bigger than ever
tomorrow i have to start the process of
change
before i get stuck in there's one thing
i want to
[Music]
oh my try
it's bloody roasting
oh [ __ ] my feet are freezing now
[Music]
molly now it's time to see if i can get
through to robert and ahri
can i just borrow you for two minutes i
want to show you something yeah both you
together i'd like to
come up to my uh room thank you
if this place is going to work as a
business robert and ari need to hear
some home truths about how their paying
customers really feel about their
precious in
uh ladies and gentlemen good morning
thank you so much for uh popping into my
room
how was your stay last night well we
didn't know where to go when we walked
in so we walked around and around until
we found somebody to help us check in
i'm slightly disoriented when i checked
in as well i mean there's no signs in
terms of reception from desk or owl
lounge or how were the rooms i had space
heaters to heat the room are you ready
when i checked the roof it was like a
sauna and he sounds aggravated raise
your hands if you come back please
not like it is
there's someone i'd like to hear from
who hasn't said anything yet he is a
lead inspector the diamond collection of
hotel and inns across america
in a nutshell
very disappointed
didn't meet expectations from the moment
i walked in
with no greeting no check-in area i was
totally lost and the bar's a joke should
not even be there folks it looks as if
it's set up for a wedding the
hospitality is nice but everything else
fails
how'd you feel
i don't want my guests to have that
experience you know our goal is to
please people that's why we're in the in
business and we've obviously fallen
really short
um for me i think that's positive
feedback so i'm grateful entirely let me
tell you thank you all can i keep you
two here please thank you the guest
feedback has certainly been constructive
thank you thank you and robert's even
using a word i've never heard from him
before we are sorry but i'm shocked by
ari's response to the guest complaints
what's the matter with you
why are you so angry with guests why are
you running and in when you're so bitter
you look like you don't give a [ __ ]
i'm not saying that i don't like the
guests but uh if you have ever been an
innkeeper
it's 24 7.
no one is more
touched by what these people said well
are you i mean
i would love this to be our our private
home but i am it's lost and ari does
have a different way of dealing with i
see that based on my experience
i would
seriously request
both you actually sit down and
reconsider
whether you should be in this business
going forward
[Music]
it's clear to me that ari isn't cut out
for the hospitality business
and even though robert now understands
how he's let down his guests he needs to
understand that he's also let down his
staff and fail to recognize their
potential i've got a plan that will help
robert to see what he's doing wrong and
how he can fix things in his kitchen
[Music]
i've asked chef julian to cook free
dishes from robert's expensive old menu
and three new dishes of his very own
creation once he's finished we're going
to pretend i cook the new ones and see
what robert says crucially junior's
dishes are all ones that could be served
on a 29 menu half what robert currently
charges look at that 74
29 let's go
good luck
okay yes
i can't wait to see what robert thinks
of julian's affordable food when he
thinks i've cooked in i asked him to
cook a three-course meal yeah he cooked
his lamb his crab cake and the dessert
that's the 74 version i cooked the other
meal
i got hold of some chicken some sprouts
and i used the crab and
butterscotch pudding with some
caramelized popcorn 29 that's what those
three courses are gonna cost okay
julian's three new dishes are fantastic
and fairly priced that would go a long
way towards bringing guests back through
the front door now that robert thinks
i've cooked them i bet he loves them
talk to me excellent
fabulous and the brussels sprouts are
really good too you've actually leafed
them and it's very pretty
this is a much better value
i've never heard you use that word value
and we could get
two
if the price had won
but we should do so my menu or julian's
menu your menu my menu
i'm flattered but there's something i
need to tell you
i didn't make any of this julian cooked
everything
i felt
at that very moment that i had done
julian a disservice
robert have you got something you'd like
to say to your chef julian i'm sorry
that i haven't given you the freedom to
do what you need to do
i guess i have to eat it
and say that i have restricted him from
being who he can be which is
is really difficult
and
i have to say that this is
delicious
coming up he's emotionally constipated
robert has a major decision about his
future with ari i think he gave up
now that owner robert's heard from the
guest very disappointed didn't meet
expectations
and sample the kind of affordable high
quality food his chef can cook when
given the chance excellent fabulous i
didn't make any of this julian cooked
everything
i hope this has all started to sink in
with him
well how are you feeling
i'm feeling all sorts of things i mean
there's of course fear
but surely hope too your chef's food was
amazing absolutely
[Music]
it was an epiphany i feel regretful that
i have
come across in the way i have
and that i haven't exhibited to my staff
the leadership they needed and the
compassion that apparently i'm
i must be void of i think for you to
tell them how you're feeling what you're
going to commit to how important they
are for you i know that this place
wouldn't be here without them and i'm
wanting to do everything i can to show
them that we can make this work
i'm glad robert's on a new path i just
hope it's not too late for his staff to
learn to trust him again you are
all valuable
to me
and to
and to juniper hill
and
i fear
that we have not always expressed that
and
we want to show you that
we are going to make a difference
sorry for your paychecks being late
sorry for
taking part of the tips
sorry for not communicating
because that was the reality and one
that i'm not proud of
that we're not proud of
but one that we certainly can correct
and that's what we want to do
the business is short of cash flow i
thought there was a substantial
collection of three to four hundred
thousand dollars worth of assets
i mean why don't you explain exactly and
the things that were assembled here um
they said lucky if we got 25 000.
we are on our ass it is going to be
difficult and i think robert has
realized
the bubbles burst
and he understands
the truth to where we are
i think there's a perception that we are
these wealthy magnets coming in and lord
of the manor sort of things that's not
who we are
you know i knew there was some
bad situations here but i stayed because
i want to be here and i want to help him
and i believe what he says and i'm very
proud of you robert you're the man that
i've always known and loved it's he's
coming back i'm glad to see that you
know we're facing facts and uh that's
the only way we're gonna get out of this
agreed thank you
ryan what do you think what robert just
said i wanted to stand up and clap i did
too
i feel like i am working for somebody
who can actually run a business when i
hear things like that that can succeed
i've never seen robert so serious this
is actually really a life-changing thing
for him and i feel like i want to be
part of the changes thank you thank you
thank you the truth's important it's
humbling to have to admit some of the
things that haven't gone right but at
the same time it's energizing to see
that people really do care for us and
care for juniper hill that is what's
going to make us successful
i'm impressed with the way robert dealt
with his staff meeting i've got real
hope that he can make this place work
but he has another lesson to learn he
thinks people aren't spending money at
juniper hill because of the recession
but i think it's the snobbish atmosphere
and the high prices that have kept
people away i'm taking robert to a
fantastic local brewery to show him how
a warm welcome can translate into money
in the bank let's go and have a beer
let's get in with the locals trust me
they won't beat you up
you are like a fish out of water right
now honestly
you're like a vegetarian in the middle
of a big steak tartare look at you
no no well i love the people from our
region the upper valley is filled with
amazing people the juniper hill is not i
know with local people wouldn't you
welcome this atmosphere oh oh yeah in
your stately house absolutely everyone
is one stand on there and tell them you
need them off we go
if i could have your attention please
i'm robert
i'm the innkeeper at juniper hillian we
just want to tell everybody we'd love to
have you all up at juniper hill inn
and uh we need the help right now so if
you can come up and have dinner or just
have a drink and just say hi it would be
great thank you
thanks
well done if robert can always be that
inviting to the locals he surely has it
in him to be the leader of the inn when
was the last time you brought arya here
for beer we haven't been here probably
in six months how was he after you spoke
to the team like that you know the
the interesting thing with ari is
his exterior is finnish you know he's
very stunned stern
but he feels deeply you can't express it
though can he he can't he's emotionally
constipated i think he gave up that
can't come across to the staff they
can't come across
the customer so you gotta almost isolate
yourself from that but he's getting
through it but he's not gonna be the
face he's not gonna be the ink no he's
not but he can provide a phenomenal
amount of support
behind the seats cheers to that
it's been a tough week here at juniper
hill inn and owner robert pompa's ways
have been maddening i don't have a
secretary gordon i'm sorry are you
always this pathetic
but he's finally come off his pedestal
to get on the same level as his team you
are all valuable to juniper hill
and we want to show you that we are
going to make a difference
overnight my team has been working on a
remarkable transformation and with
relaunch upon us it's a chance for a
fresh start for everyone good morning
good morning morning let me introduce
you to the new
juniper hill inn it's no longer a
hangout for the super rich or your mates
getting freebies yeah it's now a nice
warm and very welcoming country in and
trust me everyone is welcome whether
you're driving up here in a
mercedes or even a pickup truck
you ready yes yes let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go
please come in
come through the great hall is a
beautiful room but it was hidden by vast
amounts of furniture oh my goodness look
at this my team have edited the
collection and created a feeling of
comfort and space when i walked in the
great hall it felt like a different room
gordon put together this amazing place
it feels comfortable and warm you have a
spacious gracious
warm reception room look at it
gone
is that hideous makeshift bar
gone
guests know where to go because they
have proper signs
you ready to see the dining room yes
come through
oh it's warm and welcoming
oh i love this no longer feels like your
grandmother's parlour it really is a
dining room it's what you expect from a
country in yeah it has an identity gone
are those hideous sofas that nobody can
sit and eat dinner ari what do you think
very nice you like it very open
excellent
i'll show you my bedroom okay please
everybody else can come too please
you ready
we're ready there you go
do you know what's wrong with this room
nothing
you don't need to do anything to them
the only thing wrong was the smell in
room one and a plumber's taking care of
that
the guest rooms are the absolute
highlight of your inn that meant
something because it meant we were on
the right track we just needed uh
better directions now the key to filling
this is to charge sensible prices
i would rather have the room sold at a
cheaper price and have an 85
occupancy rate across the year in the
prices down fill it let them enjoy this
quality
the stunning bedrooms didn't need
changing but there's one room that did
need a significant overhaul in order to
bring in much needed cash flow now
there's one more little thing i want to
show you downstairs
okay
you ready i'm ready let's go come with
me
okay
we need to attract the local community
i'd like to welcome you
to the blue bar
blue bar oh my god
[Music]
the best new local bar in windsor
fantastic this is so crazy walk in and
see the people sitting there and the
games on the tables and the beautiful
drinks it was very emotional i loved it
the blue bar is exactly what the town of
windsor vermont and juniper hill in need
i'm hoping it'll be popular especially
on a day like today when the inn hosts
its first ever sunday lunch service the
staff are all getting ready for the
arrival of their lunch guests five six
seven eight so you've got four tables
each but while everybody else is busy
ari seems lost and needs reminding of
his role here at the inn
i'm here oh geez
right okay i had to go the other way are
you in are you out are you doing the
checks what are you doing i was checking
in people you're checking in but i
thought that was the great i thought you
were checking people you want to check
them in and take them up that'll be
great would you lisa kind just two
seconds i'm so sorry would you continue
that of course i'll just have you for 30
seconds
i thought you're gonna leave the front
of the house to robert i thought you're
gonna be the back of the house no one
thinks that robert asked me to to check
in people uh because he had to uh take
people to the dining room
but we have a saying in england yes too
many chefs spoil the broth you're not a
natural innkeeper
oh okay okay he needs your help but
behind the scenes just explain to robert
that you're gonna support him from
behind the scenes
please chef please i could do that i
think ari has finally got the picture
and understands that he needs to play to
his strengths i really hope that things
can continue to improve now
come on sophie we better remove the dog
she's going to eat the food
sophie our poodle she shouldn't be in
there i mean it's it's a place where we
eat come on sophie come on come come
come that's not for you come on come on
come on come on honey excuse me come on
come on i take care of the dog okay
excuse me the dog shouldn't be in the
bar he's on the seats eating the food
really i am the boss okay
don't ever talk to me that way again
excuse me don't ever and i mean it
i'll be in my room and i don't need to
be yelled at
[Music]
i'm coming towards the end of my stay at
vermont's juniper hill inn and i thought
we'd turn the corner but as the ian's
first ever sunday lunch service
approaches assistant inky pasera has
gone missing where's sargon
i haven't seen sarah in about half an
hour is she okay
i don't know you don't know okay just
ask him
has sarah gone home what has sarah gone
home
the team can't afford to be a man down
i've got to find her
where's that it's me sarah's gordon oh
hi gordon are you okay
oh no
hold on a second dude i do danny i
thought you joined us for lunch
oh thanks i'm not going to
you want to come here yeah you look
terrible what's the matter oh i'm just
really upset why don't we get upset
you're with us half an hour ago
customers are in the bar i know the
first level just arrived i just expect
you to be there in terms of you're part
of this team i know but i'm sick of
being yelled at by ari i'm sick of it
gordon when did he yell at you just a
few minutes ago because i asked him to
take the dog out of the dining room
naturally it's his dog and it's sitting
on the bar furniture please come back
down
back up and come down nobody's ever seen
me break down in tears in this end it's
never happened before just come back
downstairs okay please yeah
okay yeah i want to help i don't want to
see you upset
and the girls need you down there they
do and i'm just i'm just really mad at
them no well let me have a word with ari
this is ridiculous get yourself ready
place is full of locals and they'd love
to see you too okay please
smiley yes yes yes i'll bounce back
i'm not sure why ari is snapping at his
staff but it just proves my gut was
right about his place being behind the
scenes
ari yes
i've just found sarah upstairs in floods
of tears everything okay no we had a
little run-in because we both are very
strong people
he snapped at me and i snapped back
do you think the dog should be running
around at the bar no no we're there
so was she right or wrong she was right
would it be appropriate for you to
apologize to her
you're responsible from behind the
scenes is there any way we could just
for this first sunday lunch sure try to
keep the team together okay
i think ari's heart is in the right
place but his tone is all wrong for an
innkeeper he needs to be the power
behind the throne
i'm sure this is going to be one of the
busiest days yet at juniper hill inn and
i need to remind chef julian to make
good use of his sous chef nida if he's
going to have any chance of being
successful julian's proved to robert and
i that he has the talent and the
potential in the kitchen now he just
needs the help to execute i know you're
adam at the fact that you're gonna work
on your own but you're not a one-man
band yeah yes sir encourage entice
over the stove
the local community have responded to
robert's invitation and is a great
atmosphere as people turn up to check
out the bar and sample the new menu i
put together with chef julian tara nice
to see you welcome to juniper hill hi
are you dear nice to see you as well as
new arrivals the inn has a return guest
hotel inspector steve talon his first
visit was a disaster very disappointed
didn't meet expectations from the moment
i walked in with no greeting i was
totally lost this is robert and his
team's chance to prove to steve that
they've learned their lesson i hope this
time they're flawless
how are you mr talon nice to see you
nice to meet you
welcome so this is our new menu
what's going next coming up next we have
one trout the key to this place running
smoothly is communication among the
entire staff but chef julian still
doesn't seem to get that
how long's the first flat iron please
neither
medium
medium rare
talk to nida
i don't care what it's about the [ __ ]
weather i don't care but talk to her
okay
come on you gotta talk
i just said come on
she can put things on a plate for you
just refusing to talk to her and it'll
be so [ __ ] painful now
i simplified the menu in order to get it
so much easier for you know that yes
chef and the menu was designed for you
to open up and talk okay yeah chef look
at me
broaden your mind down and all you do is
one plate
focused next plate focus and i just want
you to open up a little bit she's there
to help
thank you
you know what let me do this
just help with the skill let's help with
the skillet [ __ ] it now julian yes come
here
[ __ ] you now what's the matter with you
you've just shut down on me now do you
want to give me your jacket i'll do it
for you no chef it's not difficult i
know chef can you do this
open up come on you just shut down
[Music]
with robert working well with the team
okay thank you so much and ahri's
staying out the way
the bar is bustling how are you welcome
what can i get you to drink
but chef julian needs to raise his game
and start communicating if we're going
to make today a success you've just shut
down on me
open up please get it together let's go
[Music]
you'll be about four minutes at that
table
so you do one plate i do one place that
good all right so then you get with the
lamb shank then you get some lamb glaze
which is right here julian nice much
better look at me max bear yes yeah good
how is everybody out there
check out chicken wow the locals are
definitely noticing a change here that
was wonderful it's very good i was very
surprised perfect that was perfect great
time to see if the hotel inspector has
two hi sir
see you again good to see you too
recognize a few changes
in some ways i didn't recognize it at
all what the uh entrance was in terms of
the total openness
of the welcoming but the signs
everywhere when you walked in with the
warmth oh it's great warmth now i feel
like it has that time collection feel
good
there's a great buzz at the end
sarah come on a second
yes
i hope that's not all about the change
i'm really
busy i'm sorry
this food is affordably priced that's
really really tasty and it's nice to
know a nice place to send people to get
a drink and relax and everything and
that's hard in the area so that's great
robert lanari's communication has
improved my leaps and bows since i've
been at the inn let's go back just first
but actions speak louder than words and
i think robert is starting to understand
that i just wanted to tell you that
i really appreciate
all the extra effort you're given not
just this week but
the entire time you've been here
and
this is your paycheck literally because
we know you need it we wish we had more
we put 100 extra in there for you just
so you have
a little bit extra because we really do
appreciate you ryan
so
thanks
and i are going to bring this back and
are he's going to join us yeah
i haven't been that
emotionally moved in a long time i
i feel like it's all been worth it now
it just i feel like i it's appreciated
what a week
i think this business is on the road to
recovery and
robert
and his team with re in the background
can really make this place work because
once the locals invest in this place
word it's gonna spend big time
wow
beautiful
it's time for me to say my goodbyes but
with the crowd enjoying themselves in
the bar and loving the great value in
the dining room it's a hard place to
leave it's really good this is nice
company and we're sharing the lamb
shakes the lamp okay
you're welcome
uh right finally you seem to got this
under control yes yes chef and you're
opening up yes yes don't stop talking
yes chef communicate good job thank you
chef he might have beat a few people
down but then he brought a few people
right back up and that was necessary i
was glad he didn't smack me with a
spatula
ari
copy i've come to say goodbye i was uh
doing my paycheck
you're writing paychecks yes good luck
with the place it's a business
absolutely look after yourself
look after robert and support him in all
the right places thank you best wishes
we are very grateful for him that he has
patience for us
because it it's not uh easy to
restructure molded minds look after
yourself yes look after yourself how are
you feeling i'm feeling great and it
seems like you've got this under control
i'm going to keep it under control well
to stop doing the job the bar is
functioning the dining room is
functioning kitchen's functioning that's
good that's beautiful always in the rv
and there are people and they seem to be
having a good time
you're on the track now we're on track i
have a little present for you stay there
having gordon come to juniper hill has
meant a lot to us
it was harder than hell but ultimately i
know it's going to do great things for
our staff and for our town this is
something that money cannot buy but this
week you've earned it now the most
important thing please keep it up this
is your side
to be part of the amazing setup the
diamond collection
thank you you deserve this thank you
well done thank you safe journey he
really did awaken me put a fire in me
and i want him to come back and say
he really did it that's our goal take
care bye
have a beautiful day
i can't believe those storage units are
still there
if i was robert i'd like ari in one of
them
[Music]
you